fix bon gommage du jour je m'excuse de
ne pas pouvoir vous embrasser tous
individuellement mais quatre mondes et
toute façon c'est en mètres et sur le
tapis cette sordide histoire de balle et
bleue organisée par le colonel a comme
elle va me manquer c'est rugby militaire
car voyez vous les petits gars vous avez
votre âge j'étais comme vous c'était
valeur fourbe et son roi j'avais le
choix entre l'armée la police
j'ai préféré l'armée parce que la
retraite est plus vite la et en y
entrant j'ai trouvé une famille un père
le colonel une mais france je sais bien
c'est bien qu'avec mavs dans les
fichiers mais c'était pour le pays mais
rappelez vous toujours j'ai été juste et
humain les rescapés des dernières
grandes manoeuvres de l'année dernière
s'en souviennent à peine les victimes
enterrées nous sommes saouler la gueule
pendant trois jours la hausse y ait eu
des morts mais quand on sait power n'est
pas là je vous remercie tous du fond du
coeur pour les jeunes en plaqué or une
fois très bien dans la boucherie oui car
l'armée m'a aussi donné à mettet
vous demandez un petit service avant de
partir une dernière fois les petits
gordes a quand même perdu l'inde aux
séries le larzac moutarde et la corse
merde
feillu s'est produit ici vous voudrez
vous simplement messieurs de régler vos
montres leroy mois le cas